oh I [ __ ] up this is stupid
hey how's gum breast my name a fat pack
today we're playing anyone to play I
play this game before it's [ __ ] scary
like someone suggested this to me and I
was like hell no I'm not playing that
[ __ ] on VR I set up a completely
different game to play today it didn't
work so I'm like well I guess I'm
playing this we'll see how it goes
[ __ ] man it's gonna be scary okay well
wish me luck if I die I die [ __ ] this is
creepy oh my god it's a black lady there
oh where did she go
[ __ ] young I'm scared I'm legit scared
already okay I trigger to grabbing 2
rags hold alright let's just go [ __ ]
okay come on I can do that thanks Kim oh
my god I'm scared your pizza's here
it's Porter pie oh my god what happened
oh it's a crazy [ __ ] I better go ah
hell no I'm oh [ __ ] a painting I can't
interact with alright we're fine I
realize I'm looking at a wall I should
probably stay like this right oh my god
there is yes how you doing there don't
[ __ ] with me my god this is scary ah
giving me the creeps man where did I
[ __ ] go where did I [ __ ] girl
you better not mama but hey how you
doing down there oh my god that's too
creepy I can't
but that [ __ ] yeah I'm I am so lost
I forgot how you played cut okay [ __ ] it
the door just open up like [ __ ] I'm on
edge man I'm a [ __ ] edge some games
you're not supposed to play in the air
okay hello hello that's me what is it oh
[ __ ] it's this [ __ ] sim sign it up
okay all right let's see here where's
the same let's [ __ ] what I keep touching
I'm so lost
Jesus Christ okay all right well let's
go in here how's that right there light
switch in here I'm so scared I'm so
scared
I just want to play ah [ __ ] oh we're
turning on the TV
[Music]
I forgot how you that say she's not
there before
oh what's me a [ __ ] so scary yet hey
we made that noise it's that fancy cars
I think we're fine
oh my god oh my god
my God where did she go I don't have a
flashlight yeah there's definitely
something down there I ain't going down
there [ __ ] you
where's the flashlight I gotta find the
flashlight right let's play at midnight
okay let's not that's weird
I'm sweating guys I'm [ __ ] where's
the flashlight I need the flashlight
oh yeah they turn off the lights right
okay I got it let's find the flashlight
I left spot
where's the [ __ ] flashlight guys
[ __ ] I ain't down for this [ __ ] man
I really ain't down for this [ __ ]
I got us at midnight oh [ __ ] I need to
get the [ __ ] out of here okay well this
is the brightest room I'm just gonna
have one one what the [ __ ] was that what
the [ __ ] was that
no oh God
turn on the light turn on the back [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you know you're gonna get this
I know
comfo Swedish gun food [ __ ]
oh my god it is so scary
[ __ ] you better show yourself before
[ __ ] Fisk you [ __ ] you oh my god I
don't like this hello
I just want to deliver the pizza
why did I try to deliver a people [ __ ]
you [ __ ] [ __ ] up [ __ ] go what do you
want what do you want what it was bit
you tiny ah she's tiny again ah good
damn it
[ __ ] that's [ __ ] hairy what happened
i die i great [ __ ] great [ __ ] okay we
need to find a flash time this time for
[ __ ] sake
flash flash light your piece that's here
every thank you for telling me how to
grab
okay let's find the [ __ ] flashlight
don't see it though oh you [ __ ] [ __ ]
how did you get there yeah damn it's so
creepy
no god damn it's so creepy I can't
that's normal there's the flashlight I
found it oh okay we have the flashlight
now he'll know
oh my god can we go down there
oh I [ __ ] stop this is stupid
I'm such a [ __ ]
Jesus Christ Dubey it's not the slicer
that is the flashlight everyone has
anyone sees that lamp I am just for
Swedish man looking for flashlight
that's anyone stays in a platter I go
maybe thank you
I should I never check this room oh [ __ ]
you
alright lady I'm here for the flashlight
and nothing else someone got a blue
screen that's bad oh look at the notes
in the paper thing they will never take
my friendship but Oh what the [ __ ] did I
just where am I and [ __ ] grant I [ __ ]
up the green screen
oh great it's midnight it's midnight
alright I'm ready for this I'm ready for
that [ __ ] wherever she comes I will
[ __ ] kill you
I will stab your eyes out and you better
show yourself where are you why did you
draw a dick always it's the controller
no none of my watch the doors stay open
that's right
[ __ ] okay I'm getting a little scared
yes the child will have no idea what's
happened here [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] up
[ __ ] you go alright I'm looking at you
I'm looking at you you can't hurt me I'm
looking at Jim what are you dabbing go
dance somewhere I'm not going to look
away from me because I know bad things
is gonna happen
oh god where the [ __ ] go why the [ __ ]
go wait a [ __ ] good where the [ __ ] go
wait a [ __ ] go when everything where
them hoes them with the hose there the
hole is there is there anything I need
to do right now
[ __ ] it's quiet okay come on what the
[ __ ] with that she's in there
but [ __ ] you that door stays open bring
it [ __ ] is that all you got
[ __ ] dabbing
Oh God oh my god you [ __ ] [ __ ]
stop dabbing that all you got
get up the couch go go go
whatever well this is [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] where is she where the [ __ ] [ __ ]
where is she
no you can't [ __ ] with me
we're oh my god you [ __ ] I hate you
go away go away go away look out go play
now
you want pizza well I got bad news for
you I ain't a [ __ ] pizza okay that's
all well I guess
time is not going forward I noted [ __ ]
that's dark oh my god that's better okay
I'm just going to try and keep
everything late [ __ ] it start [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] yeah oh [ __ ] this man I'm so
[ __ ] tired I didn't even want to play
this stupid horror game today hi today
my heart yeah well from now on I'm just
going to play what I want to play okay
Conrad the kitten oh my god it's him and
so Jeff oh you're so cute you're such a
cute puppy Conrad I love you Conrad
Conrad you're the best cat ever that's
fine go to path I am oh my god it speaks
look at him he's so cute you can do
backflips all right here you go Conrad
okay I guess not come with time why we
grill you what do you want to go what do
you want to do why why aren't you
listening to me Conrad did you walk can
you do anything you're the worst cat
you're the worst cat Conrad Conrad
move move Conrad what do I do with you
fine let's go to the [ __ ] kitchen
do you like the kitchen huh all right
what do you want you want some food eat
it eat the [ __ ] food Conrad take a
[ __ ] while you at it what are you doing
Conrad this is not how your fool Conrad
goddammit Conrad I wanted to chill out
with you you know I can't rest [ __ ] it
oh my god whatever I can leave a like
today in sisli I see a brooch in
tomorrow's video and as always have to
stay awesome and pretentious